I'm from waterbury connecticut i was
born raised in a town called Oakville
kinetic which is really kind of small
small place my father was from a town
called fort fairfield in Maine which he
grow up in a potato farm my mother is
first generation Italian American so I
think growing up a place like
Connecticut in such a small town with
you know a first generation Italian
American mother and a father whose
family kind of lived off the land it
just it made sense I don't know if it
made sense to go into a food world but
it definitely made sense for me to move
away as quickly as I could in food it's
probably the first the first opportunity
that I could that I could have utilized
I guess to get away yeah you know the
whole italian-american stuff it was it
was very cool my grandmother used to
make cavatelli fresh you know sunday to
two o'clock in the afternoon sunday
meals and big pot of meatballs and
sausage on the stove felt like all the
time you know grabbing a piece of bread
and kind of dunking it into the sauce it
was a big part of my life but on my
father's side of the family it was
interesting because we would drive up to
Maine on holidays and you know
Thanksgiving especially because it's
such an American holiday and we would
have huge I mean you know these great
feasts of all this American food and
mincemeat pies and pumpkin pies and all
the stuff that I would never get with my
Italian side of the family so it was a
great kind of balance between the two
which I i really believe and you know
the romantic idea of of all things food
I think that had a major impact on my
status with food
I was a kid I think that's uh yeah
definitely as a fat kid I you know I
took my first classes when I was 11 I
always kind of liked being in a kitchen
I had the opportunity to take a class
when I was 11 years old I took it and
then I went to a vocational school and I
actually wanted to be a plumber I had a
small period of time where I figured
plumbing was the was the life for me and
I couldn't get into the program so it's
a second choice I chose culinary arts
and it's funny kind of divine
intervention it's it's actually somewhat
knock on wood it's worked out worked out
so far Alto was the idea for outdoor
especially with the name alpha meaning
top and definitely taking a taking you
know the two schools of thought with
Italian food one is with cucina rustica
which is the very rustic style kitchen
which seems to be the one that everybody
loves and then there's the outer cucina
which I which is the high end kind of
aristocratic style kitchen which despite
what anyone would say I'm a big believer
that it's still making headway in in New
York I mean there's Fiamma with Fabio
and you know Michael White at aldo is
doing wonderful things and obviously Del
Posto with with Mark Ladner and Mario
and Lydia you know all things Joe
Bastianich is well making headway son
Domenico still 20 years in business now
they're still there looking for a new
property and that's you know there's
there's a lot of things that are still
emerging so I really saw that as an
opportunity to get to kind of raise the
bar and really create a technique driven
cuisine that was still as soulful as one
would close her eyes and imagine or in
the romantic idea of what Italian food
is so that was my that was my intention
let's put it that way
you